I think Jordan Peterson's conclusions
are terrific his foundation is weak all
of the religious people that I've had on
here have said what you said there which
is that yes of course at the micro
individual level you can have atheists
I've got plenty of their books right
here who are friends who are good moral
decent people but almost that you can't
organize a society around that which is
sort of loosely that's the jordan
Peterson perspective on this which I
think you you probably prescribed too
yes
I think Jordan Peterson's conclusions
are terrific his foundation is weak I
think that the edifice he has built on
his presuppositions I would love to get
together with him one day because I love
eyes I will see if I can make it could
you do that it would be an honor because
I I mean the way he was treated at
Cambridge you know this plan to go there
is totally unlikable what exact I mean
an educational institution to do that to
a man of his repute and his capability
you know just briefly the the saddest
part about that is you probably know I
was on tour with him for the year so I
was with him when he found out he was
getting the fellowship at Cambridge it
was the happiest I've ever seen him and
the idea that putting aside why they did
it
he has spread the ideas that you're
talking about here even if you don't
agree with his his methods completely he
has done more to spread these ideas
across the world in the last few years
than anyone on earth I would argue and
then they decided no no you can't you
can't and I think he is outstanding you
know I couldn't stand up to his
intellectual prowess he's a man of
incredible ability and courage and I am
and he's from Toronto you know and my
I'm from Toronto actually I from Delhi I
moved to Toronto my family's all in
Toronto my wife's from Toronto I have a
very great respect for Jordan Peterson
but let me give you an illustration yeah
in Ohio Columbus Ohio there's a building
called the Wexner Center for the Arts
supposedly the first postmodern building
and I asked the person what is a
postmodern building I know what
postmodern philosophy is what's the
postmodern but he said well the
architect said if life itself has
purpose why should our buildings have
any purpose and so he built it with no
particular purpose in mind you know as
stairways that I say he said what do you
think of it I said I have one question
did you do the same with the foundation
you cannot fool with the foundation you
can fool with the infrastructure and so
to me when Peterson talks of absolutes
when Peterson talks of right and wrong
not so much right and left but right and
wrong his his conclusions are very good
but the only reason I think those
conclusions stand if there is an
ultimate eternal purpose for life itself
otherwise it's just one ideology against
other especially there I suggest because
of a pluralistic society in which we
live
people start from different points in
that beginning of the argument and that
to me is where I think there is the
weakness but its conclusions and his
arguments I find very persuasive and
very likable if ultimately the
conclusions are right let's say and you
know you can argue about the the little
methods to get there do you think that
can be enough yeah I had you not use the
word enough outer said yes do you think
that's valuable do you think that's a
good way to at least have a culture I
can see why you're not gonna go with
enough okay I got a foundation part of
it is to me indispensable because that's
what you have built your theory on
however for a coexistence for a
respectability for civility I think it's
good and I think that's why I enjoy
talking with somebody like you even
disagreement can be allowed provided
provided you don't get disagreeable in
the process and I think Peterson is very
impressive that way I'd love to talk to
him on why he has not moved in that one
step see Dennis Prager for example
Dennis Prager and I have had several
dialogue going through my greatest hits
over here great man hi funny articulate
intellectual but we do agree on one
thing as a starting point that the
ultimate pursuit of life had Prager and
from
he was communing with God and the
starting point is that God has a moral
law at work in this universe when you
start from that even if you come up with
some divergent discussions on who this
God is you can have intelligent debate
but if you start purely from an auto
autocracy of good and bad then you run
into a problem in a pluralistic culture
so you basically you can't start from
the position that we we all can have our
thoughts and that they're all sort of
equal because the conversation can sort
of never get anywhere versus that there
is some moral authority beyond us and
then what you may believe related to
Jesus is obviously different than say
what dennis prager believes but but you
relish in that conversation basically
yeah and you know this is really what
I'd said and that wonderful conversation
with Dan Shapiro whom I admire so much a
great great thinker and you know I said
to Ben there's a there's a struggle
going on right now it's between the two
words egalitarianism and elitism and I
said to him we are meant to be equal as
people but not all ideas are equal we
have reversed it we have made an elitism
of people and an egalitarian ism of
ideas and that is flawed as a starting
point so if I respect all of my fellow
human beings regardless of what their
view is and see them of intrinsic worth
not worth given by the government or
state but an intrinsic valuable entity
we can converse and dialogue and
ultimately truth will triumph in the end
and so I think it is important to have
civility which is lost in America what
is what America is witnessing right now
is the destruction of sensible dialogue
do you think that's happening across the
West it seems to me the amount of emails
I get and what I'm reading and from the
countries I visited in the last year
it's not just the US but it's starting
to happen everywhere in different
degrees the West is grappling with
something I think so but you know it's
also happening in the East the only
differences in the East it is well
stright from the beginning there's no
free expression in China I mean China
China is making huge strides in this
world I think in a
McQuade globally while we are trying to
worry about each other's tax returns out
here they are building a global Empire
and we're not taking note of what it is
they are doing it's happening even in my
homeland in India there's a lot of
trouble beneath the surface in the
invasion of the private probe of belief
and so on
the thing is in America America is a
commercial culture everything spreads
faster so we notice it more here and
I've now lived here for many years and
I'm saddened to see what we are doing to
ourselves because this is a great nation
this is a great foundation so I came in
here as a stranger and God gave me the
blessing of coming here and my raising
my family and enjoying success I don't
think I'd have enjoyed this back where I
from whence I came but now what we are
doing is the vitriol the invective the
poisonous Barb's and statements we can't
seem to disagree without bringing the
person down stay with the year you know
as a debater you know we don't go with
ad hominem arguments that's a sign of
weakness anybody who attacks you
personally David is telling me they
can't deal with your argument so they're
dealing with you so I actually wasn't
planning on going here but I think this
is pretty rich place to move so what
then
do the people that are trying to do what
you're trying to do trying to do what
I'm trying to do that are trying to have
conversations what do you do in the
midst of a world that is about ad
hominem attacks personal attacks you
know what people are now are calling
canceled culture and mob outrage to
silence everyone what do you do because
I sense that it may not just be enough
to talk about the right ideas but at
some point you hit the end of the road
with that you're doing it well David
you're doing it well you know I commend
you for it you're not a provocateur you
are not stirring up people do it be
angry I'm a little worse on Twitter and
then this remember but you are
intelligently engaging and that's what
we are doing you know I'm 73 now I've
been in this work since I was 26 some
done it for nearly half a century as
long as
married I've been on numerous campuses
globally Islamic campuses Hindu campuses
Buddhist campuses atheistic campuses and
I was given an honorary Doctorate from a
Marxist University in Peru you know how
and their San Marcos honorary Doctorate
was a guy was shocked and there but the
first time one of my colleagues went
there they blocked them they didn't want
to hear them and I said what happened
how come and they said you know you're
getting us thinking noble thoughts good
thoughts you're getting us thinking in
the ways that we ought to be thinking
we've not reached there yet so I believe
ultimately God give us a book which
means the word is very important and I
just speaking nearby the night before
I'm speaking to you the number of young
kids young kids who say what's your new
tube listen to this I've listened to
that I think our only hope without
coercion is to put the ideas out there
and hope that hearts will change and
that truth and beauty will win out in
the end rather than that which is
hideous and that which is false if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell